we're on our way through the german
countryside to meet one of the
Bundesliga's most intriguing players
he's been with Hoffenheim for eight
years say odd sullia vich is known for
his free-kick technique and later this
year he'll get to show it off at the
world cup playing for his home country
bosnian Selia vich was a child when he
and his family fled the war there today
he lives with his parents in South
Germany he began his professional career
with Hareton and earned his first cap
for Bosnia while with Hoffenheim we
talked with a midfielder about his
background and how it formed him you
lived in Bosnia until you were seven
tell us about your childhood there yeah
thank you yep though the ethical
solution I just finished the first grade
when the war broke out we had to move
away I think I can't remember that much
about what happened yet night would've
either we had to decide whether to move
emigrate or stay and fight for our lives
well it's my father decided the family
should move away see that's just my
father had 19 f island so if I'm you
direct something about your first
impressions of Germany the icing of
thought for me type of many members of
my family had come to Berlin and that
made it easier for us nice long demos
Kings let's go I've got a lot of help
Thank have kept me stuck adjusted to
Germany and the people I met here pretty
quickly should I miniature I don't uh
Comiskey it didn't take me long I
learned German quite fast am I done to
my you've said that in Berlin you didn't
really appreciate the fact that you were
a professional football player what
exactly did you mean that's hot that's
that's Martin's yum it has to shed
cently think of him again if I always
loved playing football it was dead
anything Berlin's a big city you know
you never go home you go out you don't
ever relax and then you're always tired
when a practice run cleany there are
some reedus tractions in Berlin and we
were young I think a lot of people
didn't really understand that they
expected us to be dedicated football
professionals but we were just 16 17 18
that just wasn't going to happen let's
get me we wanted to have some fun I was
young with the horse 11 want to sing and
its pleasant as a footballer you live in
a bit of a bubble plaza and kind of sign
that's beautiful do you feel that some
of your colleagues have no idea how
privileged their lives are to get this
Liam fuel yeah Jetsons as also known as
often well I have my own opinion about
that loads of people with normal jobs
think oh yeah pro football players like
ooh she lives make tons of money if I
didn't forget sure it's a great life but
we put a lot of hard work into it people
seem to think that playing football is
easy but we're under a lot of pressure
it's too much at all I feel a lot of
responsibility for my family to provide
for them once I've helped to do for many
years and I've got a big family we all
went through a lot during the war we
lost many loved ones lost money to you
found me if I long to get for long there
was a lot of pressure for me it's not
such a great feeling I name is Ellen aim
is good food divided had an episode how
does your background affect the way you
play that's behind closed I think a
non-issue it has a huge effect a locked
iphone a fighter i want to win giving my
leaving baba said the muzzle I've always
had to fight my life mind if I I've
always had to look out for my family
looked after myself duh I'm not someone
who's relaxed I don't dwell on the past
if I've got a nice and I like to look
ahead whatever happens I think I was
pissy if this thing
and see that your first world cup
tournament was bosnia's coming up tell
us about what it was like there when you
qualified well I was incredible she
relief across the whole country the
sequence commenced on the food we can
see that people were really behind us
they really wanted us to make it there
was a real sense of solidarity I think
the war brought people together in
something like this made them happy
there were 50,000 people on the street
standing on their balconies it was
amazing I don't know but what did your
parents say I thought my parents cried
when I phoned them he wept with joy that
their small country was going to take
part in a world cup in brazil for the
first time i met in bosnian device